yeah welcome to yet another blitz game
is this yeah Netherlands yeah those red
white and blue sometimes it irritates
meet there are so many flags with those
colors so the color and yeah that's the
number of setups available player twins
Indian style set up let's see what why
does Sam is going for you have played d
phi f you probably will play 95 an f4
let some continue developing a half rock
you one okay at some point i need to
play the smooth
yes of course what can can play that
it's very similar to them to a reversed
semi sloth if I plain edge forward see
doing my intention is to go Bishop c5 I
cannot sacrifice I mean this is chief i
discovered okay maybe on disease no but
i can't play this anyway okay yeah yeah
but it's still it's still interesting if
i grab here i can also go King h8 this
is also possible
maybe just King edge aid ya know Queenie
five was my intention I hope it is
working i can also take if to where it's
with check here why not why shouldn't I
take I don't really see it ok and then
Queenie five cannot take g-form you want
to serve very much hanging and in fact
lots of stuff is hanging on black side
and on Whiteside g5 h7 potentially he
probably needs to take now I really okay
it seems possible
okay let's scrap and now I probably need
to retreat ok so I've got an extra pond
after all this and so it's looking ok
it's nothing particularly threatening
going on I know I want to play 5v5 would
be nice but the moment you can still
take and they can play Bishop f4 I am
can play Bishop at forum ok let's
prepare 5 prevent Bishop f4
d5 Bishop c5 yeah okay let's cover up
seven maybe rookie a drug da de and then
if I if this is the way to go okay come
on let's just take it either still
threaten me five now and taking one f6
is just yeah I cannot take on f6
basically like giving up the game I
wonder about tonight each fire physicist
maybe an idea night h5 g3 but just
partly five would be it would be
completely okay okay so you know can
that's crap and now see how I can get
the pawns going maybe maybe this way
then e five potentially 95
this is really annoying pin
yes sir I've nights you fire
its default move now pushing yeah it's a
good good pass porn
that don't see a mating attack or
something coming bishop g6 king of age
yet not too big of a big threat rookie
aid as a possible thing so just forward
yeah yeah
want to get rid of the night Genesis and
really annoying piece also d2 of course
d to look to you one Bishop see two wins
material yeah this looks good
yeah what seems to have run out of any
steams nothing nothing threatening
anymore I hope yeah okay this was the
kind of last idea d to rock age 40 gauge
for yo
t to look aged for Queens and at the end
turn just just King g8 ya think so
check that's it i hope i don't see a
threat at least check
white resigns strange game a really
strange game I'd really like to to check
to check to check this year yeah see for
Bishop c5 check now it takes King Agenor
all approved by the computer now g5 and
now it wants to play Knight ce5 winning
yeah well it's a computer yeah this
shouldn't be bad yeah ok this is also
winning yeah ok the computer I didn't
have any big improvement only those kind
of non-human moves like Nazi five-year
which you can of course play a few final
tournament game or something ever more
time then you can check if this is
winning but ok what I did is perfectly
all right yeah thanks for watching